well Celtics could not get into the
action they wanted here well they're
trying to run their horse action which
is two guys up at the top Jalen Brown
was the only one to do what to do on
that play Joe bazula calls timeout to
try to get them set Celtics have
one timeout remaining trailing by two 10
seconds to go Tatum gets it in the
backcourt seven seconds left Tatum is
fouled by heart Knicks had a foul to
give they give it with 6.8 to go in the
second overtime they're running the stop
Joe Mizzou is telling them to run the
exact same play I don't know if Jason
Tatum is going to want to start all the
way back there maybe he'll shorten it
maybe to the three-point line but
they're calling for the same play this
is the city ran hitting that
game-winning three against Philadelphia
Tatum kicks
[Applause]
Celtics in Boston
129 the final in two overtimes and it's
nine straight victories for your
father's Knicks
[Applause]
[Music]
Tatum comes off the pick and roll here
Mitchell Robinson helping out of that
strong side corner look RJ do you want
the your best player taking a potential
game-tying shot absolutely but that's
the right basketball play to a guy who
has hit six threes tonight a tough break
for the Celtics but give both these
teams credit and Incredibly competitive
and physical basketball game Emmanuel
quickly
38-8-7 in 55 minutes he's exhausted but
he's with Katie George
is at 54 minutes
[Music]
quickly still with a burst quickly no
hold for the rebound and another loose
ball foul called against Boston
sparked by the activity of Mitchell
Robinson
again that's not going to show up at the
box score but that's an extra possession
another opportunity to get to the foul
line and score Al Horford clearly with
the push there and let's see if Mitchell
Robinson can knock these down that's
missed a pair
but to my point earlier if you know he's
a 40 you got to go after that ball you
got to go after you got to put yourself
in a position right now Julius Randle is
off I do believe he has
trying to check five thousand I foul so
you don't want him to get in the tussle
there I understand that but ultimately
you need if you're in that you've got to
get yourself in that frame the
percentages say You're supposed to
Robinson hits a big first one
[Applause]
lobs it into brown brown one on one with
Grimes proud
a chance to tie it at the line for Jalen
Brown in a position to make a mistake
you just can't give up and end one
you're better off giving the lift watch
this little stumble right there thing
makes him think that he can get that
ball and that just puts him in a tough
spot
Brown missed huge free throws earlier in
the year in overtime down one to the
Knicks
this one
tied at 113.
Tatum
to come smart fires and hits
foreign
big shot from Josh Hart hands it off to
Smart two for one opportunity for Boston
as well smart finds Tatum corporate in
the corner he
[Applause]
ated
thought about it gonna give it up
quickly turns the corner into the pay
quickly ties it Emmanuel quickly doing
it all
what an incredible game here in Boston
and Emmanuel quickly tied it with this
leaner and they tried to ISO Julius
Randle he goes to a dribble handoff on
that left side Jalen brown with five
brown with three paid
up leaves it
s full overtime is coming in TD Garden
took a while to get into this pick and
roll and then he catches the ball he's
got about three seconds to make a play
121 121 as these teams both start their
first double overtime game of the season
quickly will launch
but that Emanuel quickly stunts to Al
Horford is what completely disrupted
that possession
quickly Dives inside to the rim
[Applause]
quickly
accelerates cups
and finishes a manual quickly in his bag